and also uh Cloud adoption so there's a
lot more Cloud adoption in the last two
three years so the risk associated with
this rapid digitalization uh rapid uh
embracing of remote work and Rapid use
of uh uh in increased use of uh Cloud uh
Computing uh has posed a lot many more
risks than they used to before this
situation and uh it has not been enough
uh mitigation uh for uh various
companies and that has in is shown up in
the increase in uh cyber attacks another
thing that is also uh a trend which is
mobile and Internet of Things iot's
these Technologies along with the cloud
are expected to be the fastest growing
thread Vector so they give opportunities
new technology means new opportunities
new business models new uh kinds of
customers and new kinds of businesses
but that also means that you have lot
more threats from cyber attackers so
cyber criminals
age out nation states as top three
doctors among 31 percent of respondents
so so they asked the cto's and cios like
who do you think is the most dangerous
of your adversaries and uh normally we
tend to uh see the nation-state
attackers as the top threat uh uh for us
but for many businesses which are not
necessarily critical uh for National
Security for example there the attacks
are mostly more more attacks are coming
from cyber criminals rather than this uh
straight actor the nation-state trade
actors
so what what are the different cyber
security uh rules right so cyber
security rules so uh uh you know it's
not just one kind of a job uh various
types depending on your training
depending on what you know what you like
and what you what your Acumen is in you
might end up in different types of jobs
in the field of cyber security so so
here are some examples for example you
can be a cyber uh security
infrastructure specialist so who design
uh how the infrastructure architecture
of the network architecture of the
system should be to be more secure uh
reduce risk of Cyber attack you can
become Network Security Consultants so
you will be more focusing on the network
security
you could be security analysts who would
be analyzing the various attacks and
incidents and also analyze threats and
uh figure out what mitigation steps
needs to be taken whether they are
enough if they if you're in compliance
with the standards from various standard
properties in the government
Etc uh you can also become application
security analyst who would be analyzing
the security of applications because
organizations use you know hundreds of
different applications for their
business for their human resources for
their procurement for their various
kinds of uh customer data uh
Etc so so these applications themselves
might be insecure they might be designed
to be insecure so analyzing the
application Securities another thing
Cloud security architect so when you put
your business your your processes and
your applications on the cloud and the
cloud is being hosted elsewhere there
are various security issues that come up
and Cloud security Architects actually
try to mitigate the risks that arise out
of using a shared service or like a
cloud service
you can also become blue team members
blue team members are those who actually
directly fight in real time ongoing
attacks so that you know the system
um even if it gets exposed even if it
gets attacked the blue team members can
actually work uh towards you know
arresting the spread of the attack and
contain the attack in in certain uh
cyber assets and not not let it spread
throughout your network and throughout
your databases and so on you can also
have cyber security
cyber security
software developers so we use many
different software for cyber security
for example we use
firewalls we use a network inflation
detection system we use endpoint
intrusion detection system we use uh
malware analysis tools we use antivirus
tools and so on so developing those
software is also a type of a role for
cyber security client Personnel malware
analysts people who analyze malware
especially in antivirus companies and so
on threat Hunters people who actually
actively try to find threats in your
organization uh in organizational
Network organizational infrastructure
and and try to mitigate help you
mitigate those threats so so these are a
few examples there are many other roles
so in fact nist has a very very
comprehensive guide about the various
kinds of roles and responsibilities in
the cyber security industry that you can
actually look at
so so that's the cyber security
different kinds of roles
and uh in order to become a cyber
security expert so you don't become
cyber security expert in like one day or
one month or even a year but you have to
start somewhere right so when you when
you start normally you'll learn a number
of different things not all of which you
will be doing uh in your particular role
for example you will learn about network
security you will learn about
vulnerability assessment you will learn
about risk and cyber security risk and
cyber risk assessment management you
will learn about threats and how to uh
analyze threats how to model threats you
learn about business continuity
practices in the face of a cyber
incident you will learn about data
privacy and security uh you'll learn
about how to do postmortem analysis once
and in cyber security incident happens
in your in your system you will learn
about Incident Management when an
incident is ongoing how to go about
managing the incident which includes
some communication rules compliance
roles reporting and all that you will
learn about asset and in Inventory
management cyber asset Inventory
management patch patching the uh
inventory vulnerability in the inventory
and so on you will learn about data
privacy data management identity
management for authentication and
authorization uh purposes
Etc so so all these things you will
learn in the beginning but at the uh at
the end of your
[Music]
first learning experience you will know
all of these uh but you will not know
any of these things in uh in in the
beginning in the most in-depth manner
because that's when you have to choose
that's when you choose what you want to
become like do you want to become a
network security analyst or you want to
become a vulnerability assessment and
penetration testing person and or do you
want to be a risk assessor risk
mitigator or do you want to become a
trait hunter or trait analyst you want
to become a data privacy consultant do
you want to become a digital forensics
expert or you don't want to become a you
know identity management expert uh you
know privilege access management expert
and so on so these things will come as
as you go on in your learning and some
of it you will pick up as you are in the
job so uh so that's the uh that's the
idea now here is a poll question uh that
I think Stuart will uh put in put in as
a poll so here the question is what is
stopping you from taking cyber security
certification like why uh you know
knowing that service account is so
important so there are four choices you
have to choose I can find a program uh
which is fully comprehensive I cannot I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure uh
to become job ready I find it difficult
to learn from pre-recorded lectures my
work schedule won't allow me to get
enough time for learning so which is it
that you can choose so you can get an
idea about what is stopping you uh from
from doing this so I guess uh Italy uh
to give you a few moments to vote and
then we will show the results so you
have some idea yeah the numbers are
still changing if you are on the
streaming services you can put A B C or
D into your comment or chat box but I'll
give you another about 15 seconds as we
get the last responses in from our Zoom
audience
we'll close the poll in five seconds
three two one
and here are the results
so it's about a similar except that uh
pre-recorded video is not so uh
important aspect I mean only about
quarter
I think that that's a problem but uh
more
um people are worried about uh finding
the right program
okay so we get some idea about where you
are coming from uh so so now about this
program it's a profession professional
certification program in ethical hacking
and penetration testing
yes six months long program and it has a
very comprehensive curriculum that we
have designed uh with an industry
aligned learning path so your uh you
know your live lectures will be uh give
given by uh industry experts
there are integrated labs and Hands-On
projects for practical
experience so it will not be just
Theory learning you will be actually
doing
and there are also online live virtual
classrooms with peer and instructor
interaction and it is flexible to fit
your lifestyle schedule so so it's about
10 to 15 hours of week commitment for
six months uh at the end of which you
will be uh quite a bit of an exploration
and at the end uh if you if you fulfill
all the requirements including projects
and the Capstone project etc etc then
you will get the certification from IIT
kanpur's Center for continuing education
and uh it's basically an IIT kanpur uh
stamp certificate uh it's an uh it's an
applied online learning with industry
experts Hands-On projects uh with
integrated Labs including Capstone
project we will come to what they are
and master classes monthly master
classes from IIT kanpur experts uh
including myself so so that's the uh
that's the uh overall uh program
uh IIT kanpur those of you who do not
know it's it's one of the earliest uh
Indian Institute of Technologies which
was established in 1959
it's uh it's also is home to India's
cyber security Technology Innovation Hub
uh uh the professional certificate
program uh provides you mastered classes
with IIT kanpur faculty a Capstone
project to Showcase your skills and IIT
can put certification upon completion
and uh some of you might consider IIT
kanpur on your CV to be a good
accomplishment prestigious
accomplishment uh also the curriculum
was designed and vetted by IIT Khan
so eligibility to enter this program so
you have to have a basic understanding
of programming and cyber security
uh so uh basic understanding means that
you have to have at least one
programming language preferably uh you
know some uh understanding of C for
example C language or maybe Python
language or or some other programming
language you have to have a bachelor's
degree in a related field which may
include uh you know
Electronics computers uh you know
mathematics statistics physics
etc etc with 15 or higher marks and uh
in this one we do not require you to
have a prior work experience
so another poll has come up so how many
years of experience do you currently
have
so Stuart will run and give you some
time to choose
yeah we'll just leave about um
25 seconds
okay
foreign
get your answers in and we'll close the
poll in about five seconds from now
and
here are the results
okay so uh
about half is currently standing
uh and about quarter has more than five
years
and one fifth has zero to five years uh
more more zero to three than five
okay so so some more currently studying
okay
so how this program prepares you
so first of all uh we we start with
orientation then uh there are three
divisions in the entire curriculum first
division is ethical hacking second
division is vulnerability assessment and
third division is uh penetration testing
and at the end of which you will do the
Capstone project but this is kind of
overlapping so as you see that this this
boxes are overlapping so so you will
learn these things in a in a kind of
like a rolling uh kind of a rolling
schedule and then every month there will
be a master academic master class from
IIT kanpur which is elective but it is
uh
recommended to attend because you will
learn uh something very interesting and
important uh hopefully for your future
career if cyber security is your choice
of career
uh you get to master various tools uh
you know here are some example tools
that are being shown here but there are
maybe other tools uh for example Kali
Linux is one of the penetration testing
tool box which is a web penetration
testing tool MX toolbox are some of the
threat intelligence uh Tool uh paint
there are pen test tools there are there
is um you know Network mapping tools
like in map there is Wireshark to
observe monitor Network packets and and
wireless packets and so on uh TCP dump
for capturing uh Network packets and
analyzing them uh Rob takes hping for uh
you know various kinds of uh you know
testing tools so these are some of the
tools but there are many other tools
that will come up as as we go
the kind of projects that you will see
is kind of like a industrial uh real
life situation based projects right so
for example suppose uh suppose uh in in
a vulnerability assessment scenario
let's say a production environment was
breached and we uh personally
identifiable information and personal
card payment uh
kind of information data is uh available
on the dotnet right so this is a common
theme in real world that companies
suddenly find through their brand
monitoring partner that their customer
data or some some employee data is
currently being sold in the dark net
now at this point uh you are called in
and you are asked to perform ethical
hacking to figure out how data that was
on the network uh in in some database
could have been stolen so this is more
like a postmortem analysis but you you
have to know the ethical hacking in
order to get into the mind of the
attacker in order to uh analyze what
happened and do some forensics digital
forensics on the various machines
involved the network traffic be logged
firewall logs and and intrusion
detection logs and endpoint detection
logs and analyze and and reconstruct how
the bridge happened right the reason why
you want to reconstruct is because next
time it should not happen right so
therefore unless you know how it
happened you cannot protect your system
from how it happens so therefore you
have to first work out how it happens so
this could be a scenario that is created
in a mock environment for you and you
have to reach you have to figure out how
the attack happens
similarly a bank may actually call you
for doing a vulnerability assessment and
penetration testing on in a new
application they are launching for
customers
so in that case and and let's say this
application takes credit card data bank
card data Etc so they have to be
compliant with the compliant a standard
compliance standard called PCI DSS this
data security standard of the card based
payment systems
so so here you have to not only figure
out if there are vulnerable components
being used whether there are
vulnerabilities such as buffer overflow
uh integer overflow or uh privilege
escalation uh various kinds of pointer
uh you know pointer based problems and
null pointed access
um memory leakage and various kinds of
ways the attackers can actually attack
your application and you have to come up
with the final report where you will
show that these are your vulnerabilities
in your application that you have to fix
and and I have found them either by
Consulting their known vulnerability
databases or I actually have a mock
attacked your system and figured out the
weaknesses in your application and here
is a list and now you fix it before you
launch it
so that's a vipt kind of a project that
you might get
another kind of project could be
vulnerability assessment and
exploitation there you have to let's say
you are given a website of an e-commerce
website which is uh intentionally
designed to be vulnerable so you have to
actually not only first find the
vulnerabilities the mistakes in the
design of the website in the code of the
website but also actually show that the
mistakes actually are dangerous by
exploiting the vulnerabilities and
getting into the database exfiltrating
information or or taking control of the
machine on which the web service is
running so this is the exploitation so
this is uh and and and these are just
examples there could be more but all
these things are real world real life
scenario that is happening every day in
various uh scenarios like you might have
read in the news that the Indian uh aims
the uh the all India medical Sciences
Institute in December got attacked by
ransomware and similar scenario came up
that you know you have to find out how
the actual victimization happened how
the data got data got encrypted uh how
the attack came through where it came
through uh which machine was the weakest
point that the attackers exploited and
then figured out uh before we rebuild
the system we have to figure out whether
the system is safe to be put in put in
business
so we have to do vulnerability
assessment uh penetration testing
exploitation Etc buy a safe ethical
hackers before we actually allow the
system to go back up in up and running
so this is a common scenarios
[Music]
we also have a Capstone project
which actually is a is a is a
[Music]
white project it's a it's a other
projects are basically for testing your
testing your learning right but this
caption project is actually a a project
that is designed to mimic real life
business scenario uh which can give you
true experience and which you can put in
your CV for your future employers that
look I have taken I I have done a vipt
or exploitation or or risk mitigation in
this kind of a scenario so I have I know
what I am what I have learned and what I
am talking about
so Learners can choose one project out
of several based on their preference so
you will be given several different
business scenarios and you have to do it
uh they involve real life business
requirements with virtual labs for
Hands-On learning and capital projects
are rigorous in nature and provide great
examples of your work for your uh
basically for your CV
at this point I'm going to take back the
screen sharing so that I can share the
sound for this uh brief presentation if
I want yeah
[Music]
but sorry there we go
and
thank you professor
so this is a brief presentation about
the evening platform which as I
mentioned simply learns the delivery
partner with IIT comport for the program
which means um
they're taking advantage of our
learning management system and this
gentleman will talk about how that works
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep track of your
progress every step of the way we'll
help you stay on plan with automated and
24 7 human support at the core of our
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact Real Time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you'll review key
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers the important
the reports under audience if you notice
our demographics this is super useful
especially if you're running ads for
example you could do it on social media
later you learn social media marketing
too
by looking at these numbers you'll be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting you
know what you could just focus only on
that age category show your
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes ask
your questions to top industry leaders
in exclusive ask me anything sessions
well
session of Google Trends and optimize it
okay so let's go back to here right here
where it says web searches and you can
see that there's going to be the YouTube
searches okay so now you can see that
the YouTube searches is going to be so
there's a option uh under not just web
search and there's going to be a YouTube
search okay so just go ahead and click
on user search and you should be able to
optimize your virtual
so what is Instagram app Instagram apps
refer to when we come across any sort of
original video
apps would appear within those video
contents so you will be taught when you
are watching an original video and leave
you a video app and then go back to the
original video content
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can showcase
to Future employers your learning isn't
restricted to just live classes explore
our highly effective self-learning
videos and other resources to fine-tune
your learning and remain up to date
always you can focus on different
learning approaches by subject to
personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn so
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
all right and as you can see that was a
demonstration that talked about one of
our other programs with digital
marketing and Purdue University but this
is the same platform
that we're using with IIT Concord to
deliver
the ethical hacking and penetration
testing program you saw that you can
manage your full learning path you can
access live virtual classrooms interact
with your instructors do your labs and
projects in a
a virtual machine provided to you in the
learning environment
do your tests and assessments to pass
through each course and do the Capstone
project
which includes mentorship with one of
your professors and or instructors
rather and keep track of your progress
through the course including unlocking
certificates for each module as well as
the final
certificate once you've completed the
entire program and along the way you
have 24 7 support
that makes it possible for you to um
ask for subject matter questions or
interact with your peers or ask
questions of your instructor so
all of that is available to you on the
platform
first we have I'm going to
continue here you have met doctor
uh Shukla and um
so
this is a one of the reasons why this
program is so valuable to you because
you have access to
his expertise as the program director
overseeing the curriculum so
um
I'm going to talk about learner outcomes
briefly before we get to the Q a
and
the
cohorts for this program come from a
number of different Industries
not just
software or technology but also
telecoms Financial Services retail
wholesale
Healthcare
virtually every industry is subject to
cyber security threats in virtually
every industry requires
skills of cyber Security Experts you can
see some of the hiring companies
along the right hand side from many
different Industries
and
at this point I'd like to ask
one more poll question which is
based on what you've heard so far from
Dr Shukla
are you interested in enrolling in this
program
leave this open for about
15 more seconds since it's a yes or no
question
get your answers in in the next five
seconds please
and here is the pull result
over three quarters of our respondents
said they are interested in enrolling in
the program professor
I think that's good so uh let's uh see
what what how to enroll okay
so the enrollment steps are very
straightforward
um as the delivery partner or the
program you email to us at simply learn
I will put the
email address into the chat for everyone
once you email us we will review the um
the content of your application will go
over your
educational credentials
um
do a quick test of your programming
aptitude
and if you pass the review you will
receive an admission offer
our next cohort starts in just a couple
days so day after tomorrow
um
the 8th of February we'll have an
orientation if you missed that of course
you can there'll be another orientation
before the classes start on 25th
February
um
so
the fee for the program is one lock
sixty four thousand nine hundred ninety
nine
and financing is available you can pay
it off over time zero cost financing at
the 5478
5478 rupee a month
um again put the email address into the
chat for you
so you have that available and you can
contact us
and one more question for you if you're
among those 77 percent who are
interested
and
joining the program how soon would you
be interested in doing that
again we'll just leave this open for
about 15 seconds
yeah close it in five four three two one
so about 50 of the audience just the shy
of 50 of the audience are interested in
joining the next uh February classes or
the ones just after that March or April
and if you're looking to do this more
than six months out away from now please
contact us at uh ask us at
simplylearn.net and we will make sure we
stay in touch with you and keep you
updated
answer any final questions you have and
let you know about future
editions of the program
so at this point
we're at the question and answer period
yeah so
um should we look at Q a or should we
look at the chat where are the questions
okay I have a number of questions that
I've queued up
okay from the Q a in chat so
um
turn off my camera
and
such a sigh has asked
already enrolled in a certified ethical
hacker version 12. is there any
difference between that class course and
this program
yeah so so that point that particular
program uh is usually meant for uh easy
Council certificate and this is that is
oriented towards getting that
certificate this is more of a
comprehensive uh program for ethical
hacking as well as penetration testing
and vulnerability assessment
CH is less comprehensive than than this
program I would say
and this program is more focused on
training you to have the skills to do
this kind of work yeah
does it help does it add value if if
someone already has ceh or cism
certification
so that means that person is more
um you know has more exposure to ethical
hacking Concepts from cyber security and
probably familiar with terms obviously
they will do better I mean they will
actually have probably an advantage in
the class
um
melanini uh asked if a student of law
is eligible for this program if they
have programming language knowledge and
experience
yeah so admissions will be uh based on
some um preliminary tests I mean your
programming skills so if you pass that
and being a student of Law and if you
still know programming uh that means you
are have an a keenness for this kind of
technology
and hopefully it will be not that
difficult for you to learn
um Azam asks uh
had he has knowledge but no degree is
this appropriate uh this program
appropriate for him
um
um that's a that's a very interesting
question because I know uh uh actually I
have in my organization hired people
with no degree but they are excellent
happiness and excellent penetration
testing uh people
however this is a question that simply
learned has to take a call on because
the the requirement for having a
bachelor's degree is theirs yeah they
probably can take into that take a call
on a Case by case basis yeah from from
our perspective we have a a fairly
strict requirement to have the
bachelor's degree to enter this program
there are other
programs that you can look at
that don't require a degree this one
particular does we have to maintain that
standard unfortunately
um
so there are courses of six months
claiming a master's program of advanced
cyber security
and
it
the English uh
institutions asking if it's really
um feasible to learn
through a program like this if you're
taking weekend classes and you've
started from basically from scratch will
you be able to succeed with a program
like this
yeah so as I as I said that you know uh
this this cyber security is a journey
it's not a in by itself so uh you this
six month training is a beginning of a
journey and you have to take the journey
uh in your on job experience uh with
your with your own readings and own uh
practicing what this program gives you
is is sort of like a uh you know
introduction and practice uh in the
fundamentals of ethical hacking and
penetration testing and and
vulnerability assessment uh and so that
you can actually go properly yourself uh
into a Perpetual sales learning mode uh
so I cannot say that uh depending on
where you start and depending on how uh
intensely you learn even if you give 10
to 15 hours a week for six months that's
a that's a good enough good good time if
you really focus and really give that
time I think you will be in a very good
shape to self propagate yourself into
the cyber security period
but different people learn in different
ways and different ways and with
different Focus so it's very difficult
to predict in in particularly what will
happen to you but this is the this is
how I I look at it
and this is one of the reasons why we do
the initial admission review to
to help make sure that the people we
admit to the program are committed in
ready to learn and really want to get
the benefit of it
um Cheyenne Master related question
which I'll answer which is what's the
benefit of this program over free
programs on other online platforms and
we can certainly say that the the
things you get from a free program are
generally pre-recorded sessions or
self-directed Learning Without
interaction from live instructors
without necessarily the
the depth of of knowledge being
transferred from the
institution like IIT com Force so this
program offers a great deal of value
over just the free self-study programs
and and
simply learning yeah go ahead
also the practice Labs on Virtual
virtual environment which is not
available outside that's correct and and
culminating in the Capstone project
which is uh
real exercise of of showing off all the
skills you've learned and demonstrating
them in a real world uh problem solution
that you've built yourself so
um
we have a couple of questions about
philosophy or state of the art um chime
asks what is your view on the overlap
between AI
and Pen testing
yeah I am fantastic well uh pen testing
is a method by which you penetrate a
network penetrate a computer or system
uh by exploiting vulnerabilities to show
to your uh whoever hired you that his
system or his Network or his uh his
server Etc are vulnerable to attacks and
if uh if if a external adversary finds
it they will certainly attack it so it
better find uh what what uh you know
what can happen to him so so he can fix
it and he can get mitigation measures he
can put firewall rules he can put
various uh anti uh virus and endpoint
detection and response system and things
like that uh of course uh
nowadays this to do this penetration
testing sometimes you have to write
programs which will actually do the
exploitation right so you don't you know
you cannot uh continue to uh you know
hit the system with a particular
you know HTTP message manually again and
again before you succeed so you may have
to automate these things so nowadays
with some of this automation can be
powered by AI generated code and things
like that other than that Ai and
penetration testing
um really does do not overlap as such
you can also do penetration testing of
an AI system which is like a chat deputy
and and things like that you can also
have chat GPT write a code for you to do
penetration testing so so there is some
connections but that's rather AI can be
brought to the service of a penetration
tester for automating his manipulation
testing activities
thank you
um garage asks uh what do you what do
you see as the
the future scope for advantages of a
career in as an certified ethical hacker
see uh and
um so you don't uh choose to be a
certified ethical hacker forever right
so you want to grow in the in your
career by starting somewhere and that
would be that would very well be a
certified ethical habit you will be
hacking uh to expose weaknesses in the
system of your employer and then uh
eventually at some point you will have
so much expertise that you will be
managing probably a set of a you know a
team that does risk assessment risk you
know mitigation uh in which the ethical
hacking is one of the ways to uh you
know assess risk and then over time you
might move to become a stock analyst or
a security operations center on the list
and and then a security Operation Center
leader uh and then maybe you know and in
one day you will become a c show so I
would say uh becoming a certified
ethical hacker is a step towards a
career in cyber security but this is
this is not a permanent career as like
like programmers right so nobody remains
a programmer throughout their I.T career
they they start with programming then
they become designer software design
architect and then they become a
consultant then they become uh you know
strategists and then they go go into
various uh other roles uh so uh so I
think certified ethical hacker for young
people is a very good choice because it
actually is a lot of fun uh to actually
show that you can actually get enter a
system but at the same time if you do it
without being a certified ethical hacker
and without being in employment of the
person whose system you are penetrating
you might go to jail so so if you want
to become a they want to have the fun of
penetrating other system exploiting
other systems but not go to jail then
you might as well become a certified
ethical hacker and put your skill to the
service of an organization which will be
protected because of your skills so I
think it's a it's a good career choice
for young people
I think one of the reasons why certified
ethical hacking evolved was that the
the the uh official organ entities you
know fish government agencies were tired
of taking people out of jail who had
been sent there for hacking and they
wanted to have people who are trained to
do the same thing
um
Nicholas asked an interesting question
which is a
do you think that uh state agencies or
other cyber security organizations
actually keep their eye on Cyber
Security Professionals so that if you
become a certified ethical hacker that
there will be somebody watching you
I think I think that uh they're always
looking for talent scouting for talent
uh so if you become uh well known uh in
the certified in the hacker Community
you certainly will uh get attraction
again I will attract attention but
that's not because they want to uh you
know persecute you but they are looking
for talents
thank you
um
and I want to ask or answer a question
myself here from melkor who asks if we
offer scholarships or other financial
assistance or how the financing Works uh
we do not offer scholarships or
bursaries but um the uh no cons and the
no cost financing allows you to enroll
in the program start the program and pay
it off over time so that it's not a
matter of paying all the way first and
then
um enrolling so what is the the last
question I'm going to take here is a
fairly typical of several
user Tango
says he's a banker with 47 years of
experience
um
and
as MCA qualification
how would a course like this help
somebody at that stage of their career
to move forward
let's see says eight years of banking
experience is 47 years of age
ah yeah so 47 years of ranking
experience yeah
right yeah so I think that if you are so
banks are one of the major
um you know users of cyber security
talents cyber security tools and
Technologies and Frameworks and and they
I'd be uh probably the most
aware of cyber security risks and and
they actually I do work with many
Bankers including the Central Bank of
India and I know that banks are very
serious about cyber security
so now the question is that if you are a
banker and you want to move uh away from
your business
rules into a cyber security role uh you
probably I would suggest you probably
talk to your cyber security team because
uh it depends on how accepting they are
to such lateral movement but uh it's the
I know that the banks hire a number of
cyber security you know ethical actors
diversity Architects network security
consultant risk assessment and risk
management Consultants they hire various
types of roles for data privacy data
loss prevention architect and so on so
there are many roles in the banks for
cyber Security Professionals the
question is that will they hire somebody
that they uh or they who has domain
expertise uh I think for risk assessment
and so on it might be actually
beneficial for the bank to hire somebody
with trained in cyber security after
having the domain knowledge of banking
but it's up to the bank and the CCO of
the bank and the organization so I
cannot tell you uh for sure but uh
domain expertise can help in certain
areas of cyber security especially in
risk assessment risk mitigation uh kind
of thing
yeah and and the point about domain
expertise I think applies across all
industries that if you come into a
program like this with deep domain
expertise and you learn this set of
skills and you can provide some great
insights to your employer or to other
Employers in that domain
um so at this point uh apologize for all
the questions we could not get to
I'm going to go ahead move to the last
part of our
um
presentation
so a final poll question
and with this poll question if you are
interested in receiving a proof of
attendance for this
session
please answer yes to that but also if
you're interested in getting assistance
in enrollment
um
let us know
and we'll leave this open for another
five seconds
again if you uh would like a proof of
attendance for this webinar
please click yes and we'll give you
three
two
one
all right
and about
half of the
respondent said that they were
interested in getting assistance so the
best way to do that of course is to
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
um the QR code that you see there
will take you to the
program page on our website
and I let you download the syllabus and
get other information but the best way
to get answers to your questions is
through ask us at simplylearn.net
so at this point I want to thank Dr
Sandeep Shukla for being here today and
sharing so generously with his time and
knowledge
thank you doctor
thank you thank you uh Stuart and uh it
was a pleasure so hopefully uh all of
the attendees got the information they
wanted and uh hopefully see uh some of
them in the course
and um
again I'll reiterate that thank you all
for being here today
um we hope to welcome you into the
Learning Community with IIT contour and
simply learn
and that concludes our webinar
thank you